Titus why are you such a fan of Easter
oh any excuse to cook fried chicken
macaroni and cheese yeah to
um the Easter eggs you mean these I have
some right here yeah here you go and we
actually have a rapid fire round of
Easter questions for you um because
you're such a big fan of Easter will you
do the final five Easter edition
[Applause]
all right take it away Easter Bunny okay
all right up up first name someone you
worked with that you'd say is one good
egg
Ellie Kemper really is she as nice as we
wanted she is
[Applause]
great all right question number two you
have to pair up with one person for an
Easter egg hunt uh from these choices
who would you pick Jane kakowski Ellie
Kemper or Keegan Michael Key Keegan why
because he's
a badass and he's going to win no matter
what I was going to say that he's going
to be good at the hunt yeah he's going
to win all right next question so it's
Easter you've been binge on brunch
everybody goes home what show are you
binging on oh
um interview the vampire on uh AMC it's
so good really yeah I've seen previews
for it it looks really good it's really
good but no Brad Pitt or Tom Cruise in
it no oh but it's still good it's still
lovely understood under I'll watch it
okay great all right next question where
is the most inappropriate place to hide
in Easter egg
yeah that's
yeah oh yeah
yeah you don't want to find one floating
in a toilet no
all right number five so you're going to
an Easter party what is a gift that you
bring a host oh goodness a bunny a
chocolate bunny yeah yeah okay follow-up
question when you eat a chocolate bunny
do you go ears first or bunny tail first
it's a fair question
ears
let's go to town
[Laughter]
before we go you play the narrator on
schmidoon Whose life would you want to
narrate in real life oh
Gail King oh God she comes here I find
her so endlessly fascinating she's so
smart in a way that is dissimilar to
Oprah they're both like you know thought
leaders but she's just so she's such a
classy woman I like I want to know what
she you know what kind of wine does she
drink what kind of when did you take a
bath what does she listen to well maybe
not but you know what I mean yeah I just
think she's great yeah is that weird no
no and I feel like we should do some
sort of introduction
oh you do yes but she just doesn't know
that I like her like that
well maybe we need to all go on a double
date yeah and we won't be attracted to
each other so there's that you won't
have to have sex I know I I by the way
that's what works with me and gay men it
lasts forever yeah
yeah we make her very hoppy yes you do
Titus I'm so happy to hang out with you
thank you so much for like being so
heartfelt and keeping it real my fellow
Pisces
streaming now with new episodes every
Wednesday on Apple TV plus and before we
go can we take a quick pick with the
Easter Bunny all right let's do that
we'll be right back
[Music]